[Applaus]
ich muss arbeit geförderte projekt von
jean becker ist ein film über kinder
wohnen sie uns gut ist in die namen der
drei kinder
sie gehören nicht unbedingt zur sozialen
idee in amerika im gegenteil sie gehören
so einer schicht die man als arm
bezeichnen müsste faktor sind movie und
halle ihre mutter wohl auch obdachlos
sie leben in einem hotel wechseln dort
gelegentlich das zimmer damit es nicht
so auffällt dass sie permanent dort
leben eigentlich wäre das gar nicht
erlaubt dass man so die obdachlosigkeit
kaschiert und das paar darf auch eines
großzügigen hausmeisters eben mit robbie
der darüber hinwegsieht dass er hier so
etwas wie kann man ente gäste in einem
hotel hat das eben eigentlich für
temporäre gäste vorgesehen wäre nach ein
mal und ist raus
der song hat noch nicht richtig begonnen
und was soll ich sagen
butterfisch im pool die armut oder die
sozialen probleme die moni und ihre
mutter haben die im zentrum des films
dann vor allem sind werden nicht so
gezeigt dass der film eine elends
reportage wäre im gegenteil schon becker
zeigt uns das leben dieser drei kinder
als ein ständiges abenteuer sie streunen
herum sie machen sich die welt zu eigen
sie spielen kleine streiche
[Musik]
die mutter hat sehen wir dabei wie sie
versucht so wenig wie möglich ihrem kind
erkennen zu lassen
die brachialen ag ist als mutter die
eine schande
das zeigt uns schon becker vor allem aus
der perspektive der kinder
das heißt r8 jetzt sehr stark darauf
dass wir auch einen eindruck davon
bekommen dass wir die welt so wahrnehmen
wie man sich vielleicht vorstellen
könnte dass kinder die welt wahrnehmen
das ist dann eben eine welt in der die
farben sehr intensiv sie in der das
nicht sehr intensiv ist in der der tolle
kameramann alex sap eine ganze eigene
stimmung eben erzeugt videos platzen
können was immer es ist wohl auch
wichtig bei seinem film das einst damit
macht damit dann die aufmerksamkeit eben
sich darauf richtet weil ihm der faux
ist wie ein vater für dieses kleine
ensembles aber wirklich stark sind die
kinder sind ihre mütter schauen becker
findet seine darsteller zum teil auf
instagram account so ganz anders als
anderweitig die leute carsten ich habe
euch gewarnt ein klecks und africa
submarine fing der mann wirklich
empfehlen kann denn er zeigt unser in
amerika wie man es ganz heftige kino
sieht ein amerika in dem sehr wohl
soziale probleme eine große rolle
spielen indem aber auch immer noch etwas
lebt von dieser mythologie des
amerikanischen traums in diesem fall
sind es im kinder die dieses amerika als
eine immer noch traumhafte landschaft
erleben und die spannung in der sie das
tun macht der freude oder projects vor
dem wirklich interessanten sehenswerten
ästhetisch interessanten film
mannomann ist das krass